So Donald Trump recently changed his rhetoric
on Corona virus and reportedly it is not because
he realized this is a serious problem.
It's because a aides explain to him that his
own supporters are getting sick and dying.
Last week, we sort of noticed the change in
Donald Trump's tone on Corona virus.
Like as an example, he restarted these Corona
virus press briefings.
And at the first one, he regularly pulled
out his mask.
He has the mask with them sort of as a prop
now talked about the importance of wearing
masks, said it may get worse before it gets
better, which, you know, any admission that
anything that everything is not perfect is
kind of a big step with Donald Trump, who
is suggests that everything's fine since the
start of this pandemic up.
However, it seems as though the reasons are
different than the ones maybe we imagined.
Our initial analysis was just a simple.
Trump's desperate.
He understands he's losing in the polls despite
publicly insisting that he's not losing in
the polls and the polls are fake.
We actually know that internally.
Trump has been furious about polling in which
he's losing to Joe Biden.
But now, according to a new poor report from
The Washington Post, people close to Trump
claim that the reason Trump's tone has changed
on Corona virus is because advisors have brought
him maps and they've explained that our people,
as they call them Trump voters, are disproportionately
getting sick and dying.
And they actually showed Trump some projections
that if we continue to see these spikes in
battleground states, Minnesota, not so much
a battleground state anymore.
Wisconsin, Michigan, etc., that it could disproportionately
hurt Trump because it would be more of his
supporters that might end up getting sick
and dying.
Now, there are a few things here that are
completely outrageous.
The first is, again, the total lack of empathy.
We know Donald Trump seems almost constitutionally
unable to experience empathy.
And indeed, if one thing gets him to change
his tune on Corona virus, it's getting told
that his own voters may be the one that die
from the virus.
It's another indictment of Donald Trump's
personality and morality and total lack of
empathy.
But the really wacky thing here is I've been
asked essentially this question for months
on Friday, questions on live calls via email
voicemails.
People say, you know, David, the leftists
are more likely than the right wingers to
wear a mask to observe social distancing to
take the virus more seriously.
Is it possible that this will lead to more
Trump ists dying from the virus and maybe
affect the election in November now?
It's, of course, theoretically possible and
even plausible.
But the numbers to flip a state would have
to be really bad to the point where you have
such a degree of death and so much more among
would be Trump voters than would be Biden
voters, that it could really impact the election
results.
But it seems that this is actually becoming
a consideration within the Trump campaign.
Republicans ignoring guidelines that are being
followed by Democrats could kill just enough
additional Republicans that it hands Donald
Trump a loss in some state in November.
And what's notable there is the partizan difference
in the care that different people are taking
and the seriousness with which our side is
taking the virus.
And it's becoming politically relevant.
This is really no different than when, you
know, an anti-gay Republican changes their
view because they have a kid who's gay or
a nephew or a niece or something like that.
It's just on a grand scale.
Trump is changing course.
When it finally impacts him directly out of
personally selfish reasons.
And November could be an absolute rebuke of
this absolute lunatic.
And we've got to take the Republicans in the
Senate down with us because this is nothing
short of a death death cult at this point.
And they have to be voted out on November
3rd.
There's really no other alternative.
And what has finally gotten Trump to pay attention
to Coronavirus is that his supporters may
be dying at greater rates than Democrats are
dying.
And, you know, a few people emailed me.
They said if Trump loses in November, he will
always have coronaviruses.
The excuse, Trump will say, I handled coronavirus
beautifully.
I was the victim of circumstance.
And the reality is that it is true in a literal
sense.
And Trump will never realize and certainly
never admit that he was simply a disastrous
president.
His delusions of grandeur, his narcissism,
would not allow anything else.
He'll say he lost because the virus happened
during his presidency.
The truth is actually quite the opposite.
National emergencies often strengthen the
incumbent.
And there are many world leaders right now
who are more popular than ever because they
took this seriously and they handled it well.
New Zealand comes to mind.
Finland, Ireland.
There's a whole list of places.
Trump's approval rating actually went up early
in the pandemic because of that rally around
the flag effect.
George W. Bush benefited from it in 2001 after
the 9/11 attacks.
Bush squandered it by going into Iraq after
a group of Saudi Arabians attacked us.
Trump again had the opportunity squandered.
It didn't take the virus seriously until like
10 days ago, said 15 cases will soon be zero.
Everything's fine.
We have the most in best testing economies
coming back, etc., etc..
This is a president who turned a health crisis
into an even bigger national catastrophe.
And the reality is, had he handled it well,
he would be sailing to reelection today.
We have to make sure he doesn't.
And after all this, if he were to get reelected,
we've just wasted a really an unconscionable
amount of time.
Let's not allow that to happen